We have this system
of equations here.
3t plus 4g is equal to 6.
And we have negative 6t plus
g is also equal to 6.
And there's a bunch
of ways you can
solve systems of equations.
You can graph them.
You can solve by substitution.
Whenever you see the
coefficients on one of the
terms, in this case the
t term, they're almost
cancelable.
And when I say cancelable, if
I add 3t to negative 6t, you
won't be able to cancel
them out.
The t won't disappear.
But if I were to scale the 3 up,
if I were to multiply it
by 2 and it becomes 6t, and then
I were to add these two
things, then they would
cancel out.
And I would be left
just with g's.
So let's try to do that.
And now remember, I can't just
multiply this 3t by 2.
In order for this equation to
hold true, anything I do to
the left-hand side, I have to
do to the right-hand side as
well, and I have to do it to
the entire left-hand side.
So let me multiply this
equation by 2.
So I'm multiplying it by 2.
So let me just write it here.
So I'm going to multiply
2 times 3t plus 4g is
equal to 2 times 6.
Anything I do to one side, I
have to do to the other side.
The equality still holds true.
So 2 times 3t is 6t plus 2 times
4g is 8g, is equal to 2
times 6, which is 12.
So I really just rewrote the
same information, the same
constraint in this
first equation.
I just multiplied
both sides by 2.
Now, let me write the second
equation right below it.
I'll write it in orange.
So the second equation right
here is negative 6t plus g is
equal to 6.
Now, think about what
happens if I were to
add these two equations.
Remember, I can do that because
I'm essentially adding
the same thing to both sides
of this top equation.
Or you could say I'm adding the
same thing to both sides
of this bottom equation because
the other equation is
an equality.
This negative 6t plus
g, it is 6.
So if I'm adding 6 to 12, I'm
really adding the same
quantity to the left-hand
side.
That's why I can do it.
So let's add the left-hand
sides together.
When we do that, the
6t's cancel out.
That was the whole point behind
multiplying this first
character by 2, so that the 3t
becomes a 6t, and we're left
with 8g plus g is 9g, is equal
to 12 plus 6, which is 18.
Divide both sides by 9, and you
are left with g is equal
to 18/9, or 2.
So we've solved for g.
Now we can substitute back and
solve for t, and we can use
either of these equations.
Let's use the second equation
right here.
So we have negative 6t plus g--
we just solved for g; g is
2-- is equal to 6.
And we can subtract 2 from both
sides of this equation.
Subtracting 2, the left-hand
side of the equation, that
cancels out.
You have negative 6t is equal
to 6 minus 2 is 4.
Now I can divide both sides of
this equation by negative 6.
And we're left with t is equal
to-- what is this?
t is equal to negative 2/3.
And we're done.
We've solved for a t and a g
that satisfy both equations.
We just saw that it satisfies
the bottom one.
If you want to feel good that
it satisfies the top,
substitute them back
into the top.
Let's do that.
3 times the t we got, negative
2/3, plus 4 times the g we
got, so plus 4 times 2.
Let's see what that is.
3 times negative 2/3,
that's negative 2.
The 3's cancel out.
Plus 4 times 2 is 8.
Negative 2 plus 8
is equal to 6.
And that's exactly what that
first equation got us.
So these two values definitely
satisfy both equations.